[Music]
I want to grow and I want to learn and
if I do things that are just safe then
I'm not gonna experience the things that
I don't know about myself
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back for a
brand-new edition of collider ladies
night I am so excited for this one
because you know this is Jesse Buckley
and she is incredible I'm just gonna
embarrass you right off the top I have
seen Wild Rose a couple of times now and
please go check out that movie because
seriously you are phenomenal in it I
can't get that music out of my head
sorry about that country singer nobody
wants to see a convicted criminal out
there Johnny Cash's a convicted criminal
you ball bag
Crabtree music the speakers in the truth
just get so Evers in the wrote I should
have been born in America I'm an
American young incredibly talented
there's nothing you can't do I want that
end song to get an Oscar campaign so bad
and I truly mean it not just because
you're sitting there but it almost
reminds me of the effect that a sing
street had on me know where I walk yeah
I walked out the door I had to download
everything and I was hardcore rooting
for it so I hope it works out who knows
I want everybody out there it's kind of
get to know you a little bit because
you've had a really interesting journey
that to be completely honest I wasn't
even aware of until I started prepping
for this interview so way back when do
you remember what the first thing you
got into first and really wanted to do
was was it being in movies was it
singing or the stage work oh god no like
my groping in Carrie I mean even you you
didn't even think about being in movies
because that belonged to Hollywood and I
grew up with a foot of a mountain in
Carrie so that wasn't even something
that was a thought that I would ever
ever get a chance to be part of so
really my first kind of look into the
you know mad house was through musical
theater and my mom is a harpist and a
singer so we grew up around lots of
music and my dad is a bar manager but
always wrote poetry and stuff so that
we're always like in a house where we
were doing some kind of musical social
suicide music camp or something like
that but I moved to London I was 17
trying to get into drama school to study
musical theater but I didn't get in and
then I ended up getting a job and then
went on to do a play in the West End for
13 months and that was my first thing
really is that the first thing you
wanted to be when you grew up was a
stage actor uh your eyes yeah definitely
like a theatre and live performance and
loved like I remember going to see John
was Joseph and his Technicolor Dreamcoat
or something
ridiculous like that in my life we think
of every like child of our generation
has a weird special memory with that oh
my god
and I truly believe that Jesus had died
on the cross in my hometown in Killarney
like in the horas Podrick which is the
Town Hall and why I was so upset by this
experience that Jesus had died in front
good Catholic Irish girl
Shh bring me backstage to make sure me
that it was only like Mick Sullivan from
down the road who is actually going to
the pub in half an hour and Jesus had
risen so I that was kind of my first I I
just always I love the magic of it you
know I love that moment in the theatre
where I always feel like it's you're
stepping into a beehive and you can hear
all these bees and people getting ready
for this three hours moment of their
life which is being transported into
another world and and I think the first
movie I saw was meet me in st. Louis
VIN Simonelli and I couldn't believe I
couldn't believe it I couldn't believe
the colour
I couldn't believe watching Judy Garland
like sing like that and have that kind
of oh yeah anyway I could talk about
this forever that's what the show is for
talking about the things you're
passionate about so do you play a lot of
different instruments too based on your
mom's influence yeah we grew up playing
a lot of different instruments from oh I
played the harp kind of altering my
childhood my teenage years and then
piano and clarinet
although all the character Buddhists
yeah maybe I should just become of those
people that walks alone you know with
the big drum and kind of those dinky
things you should you're doing like a
live like a show for a wild rose right
you should incorporate that yeah like a
traveling salesman man did you ever try
an instrument and not be able to pick it
up cuz thinking back to when I was a kid
I found the saxophone and that was like
my thing and that naturally came to me
but if I tried the piano or just about
anything else too
guitar or singing it couldn't do it huh
I probably a bit more scared about
picking something up now like I've tried
to stay playing the guitar and I just
play it because I learned to play a bit
for wild rules and I just can't believe
how shy do I sound oh I haven't had the
nerve to like keep it going but every so
often I'll take it out and you know sit
outside and go come on come on try and
play sing to me it's like only way to do
is to be able to just like pick up a
guitar and hang out and be able to play
but I can just enjoy other people's
music so I did not realize you had a
reality-tv background and it's strictly
because I didn't watch the show so
hearing that whole story I was like kind
of shocked but you went through all that
Jessie
[Music]
absolutely nothing to say to you I mean
you're coming are you
I can't believe that he's so curious so
many years later because based on the
reality TV that I do watch I know there
must be some crazy things that go on
behind the scenes so looking back is
there anything that makes you think out
like I can't believe I did that for that
show yeah loads well I I think it was
kind of funny it was an amazing
experience and and looking back no I'm
quite you know I was very ignorant and
innocent the whole business of what that
was and it was kind of what brought me
over to London in the first place and I
ended up doing it because I didn't get
into drama school and I was just
practicing for my next Drama School
audition so joined the queue of this
reality show which is the Nancy in the
West End and Andrew Lloyd Webber was
kind of hosting the reality show and
then I just ended up going through it
but I am I
oh yeah I look back at that 17 year old
version myself and go oh my god that's
pretty ballsy like I had no training I
was so raw I was so bad publicly so many
topic and yeah you know I was just so
excited and to be part of this family
that I thought would take you know at
least three decades to even touch upon
and yeah so it was a kind of an
incredible experience and art is well
very odd to wake up and you know it's
seven o'clock and you look like hell and
there was like a camera there watching
you put milk on cornflakes which I don't
really know why it's on you know
exciting to watch but that was probably
yeah that was quite weird I feel like
think about those like random little
like everyday ins and outs of life like
what do you eat for breakfast I don't
know there's something that humanizes
yeah and especially when it comes to
like any kind of like performance art
that I admire those are always the parts
of the reality shows that I don't know
like puts me on that same play same
wavelength yeah yeah definitely do you
keep in touch with anyone from that show
cuz
when I was doing my little research I
was scrolling through the cast list and
I saw Samantha barks his name you got me
all five because of course she's
incredible it is yeah uh yeah I always
spoke to her a few weeks ago actually
when we were in New York and and Rachel
talker is another girl that I stay in
touch with and I'm drew I stay in touch
with her he's really sweet and kind of
text oh well not text he sends somebody
more official than email yeah so we meet
off sometimes and have a cup of tea and
just check in and yeah he's been really
amazing that was the coolest thing about
reading about your journey with that
show too because I think the idea
especially in this industry of having
mentors or someone to look out for you
to take you under their wing is so
important to put you on the right path
so in addition to him is there anyone
out there that you look to and your leg
thankfully you were there and you gave
me the right advice oh my god yeah I
mean I feel like I've been so lucky to
me and make like incredible people and
lots of different points of my life and
journey so far I was really like there's
this one when I moved over first you
know I didn't have a family or I'm the
oldest of five so once you're out of the
house you're like out of the house and
you gotta learn you gotta do it yourself
and there is a man called
who had come to see me in little like
music and he just was like I just want
to support you learning and but said you
know pay for me to go to singing lessons
and paid for me to go back to Rada and
and he has nothing to do with the
industry but he he I suppose he had a
little hand on my back and told me keep
going cuz you've got something so but
I've been lucky there's been lots of
people along the way it's so encouraging
to hear that that someone just wants to
you know jump in because they believe in
what yeah yeah yeah kindness of
strangers it was really I'm
and he's an angel like this I definitely
wouldn't have been able to learn and
grow the way I did without them you're
still growing yourself and I can't wait
until the point where I could say like
you're a household name hopefully when
this movie comes out and everybody sees
it and everybody knows Oh wonderful you
are but even this early on is there
anybody in your life or in your work
where you're looking at them and like
you were able to give them some advice
or make sure that they did a certain
something a different way oh no I
wouldn't I wouldn't be cocky enough I
don't know I think everybody's got their
own journey I mean I went home to my old
school back in Ireland
last week my younger sister still there
and and it was a really amazing thing to
go back and and talk to the girls and
you know we've got to look out for each
other and everybody's got their own
little unique beautiful journey that
they've got to go on and I suppose it's
to encourage people to nurture their
into that individuality in their opinion
and educate themselves in lots of
different ways whatever that is and
whatever it is that they're passionate
about but but to find something that
they're passionate about and go first
you know take risks so I don't know
maybe you probably were bored and just
wanted to go for a long and then you say
something like that and I'm like I wish
I was I was so nervous about it because
I'm like emotional doing it because it
was a lot about what you say to yourself
at that age as well and I definitely had
points when I was that age where I was
afraid of myself and I I did everything
to go against how powerful I could be
because I was afraid of what that might
feel like because it's big and every in
all of us and sometimes it just takes a
while to accept that yeah no I get that
actually speaking of that I was also
reading that you had a bunch of
opportunities after the reality show and
you decided not to do them so I'm so
curious looking back is there any one of
those gigs that you could have gotten
that might have
change the course of your career in a
way that you ever think about anymore I
don't really think I think like what's
mentally doesn't pass you by and there's
so the life's full of sliding doors like
you can I don't know fall in love with
ten different people in one day but you
just choose to go down one path yeah I'm
sure there's been other moments where I
could have chosen something else but I
didn't so I don't regret anything
speaking of saying so like saying no to
something can be very hard whether
you're in this industry or any other
industry if like you want to climb to
the top you think to yourself I mean
I've thought about this too like I
shouldn't gobble up every opportunity I
can get but the chance to like sit and
think and really carve out the right
path is super-important so can you talk
a little bit about like your mentality
when something good came your way but
you had to say no for a very real reason
yeah I think it's important to learn to
say yes as well you know or to say no I
mean too late to say no because you have
to have an opinion about your own your
life and just because it might give you
a lot of money or whatever you have to
really ask yourself what it is you're
looking to experience at that point in
your life and I think it's always good
to come away you know it's even
especially after a job I always want to
like come away a and you have to reset
and reflect and what you've taught
what's changed with you within that job
or within that year or whatever and get
hungry for the next thing and I
definitely feel like I want to do that
more and be conscious about what I'm
curious about exploring and not just
take something because it's there
because I want to I want to grow and I
want to learn and if I do things that
are just safe then I'm not gonna
experience the things that I don't know
about myself yet I really respect that
mentality and that's why we get
different unique very very spunky
characters like it really is very
impressive to be able to take somebody
who could initially be a very unlikable
character
to turn her into someone who you feel
for on so many different levels and
you're rooting for her to succeed yeah I
mean I never I never found her unlikable
I think I found her frustrated and
complex and and trying to figure out how
to move forward in her life and we all I
mean she's foiled and she's fractured
and she feels she I remember in a cold
tale who wrote the script said she's
she's Rosalyn is alive she's more alive
than you and you can feel like every
sinew of her being reverberates on the
outside of her skin and sometimes that's
like a tornado which rips through the
cities that she's like living in and
sometimes it's she's able to pull it all
in and sing it out and say everything
that she's trying to say in her normal
life but in this other world when she
sings but I just think she's human I
can't I I don't think there's anybody in
the world who doesn't have those
feelings and those selfish moments or
moments which don't come you know they
all come with a consequence for her I
think even when it appears that she's
being selfish I feel like frustrating is
probably the best word to describe her
because you see all these like these
wonderful qualities in her and you're
like why did you like what I can't
believe that even after seeing this
movie multiple times that scene just
like it's still it gets me all riled up
all over again going back to the
beginning of Wild Rose is this something
you had an audition for or did they
reach out to you for the part I had
worked at Tom Harper before the director
on war and peace and oh yes yes laid
quite an unlike character in Princess
Marya so I don't know why he saw me in
that he's like you're perfect for wild
roots so he sent me the script and he
said I want you to have a read and I
only really want to do it if you do it
and it was just such a brilliant script
and then when I met Nicole it kind of
just went from there so that's kind of
came my way is there an intimidation
factor jumping into this such a like a
rich storytelling and character arc
opportunity but there there's just so
many elements of this production that
I'm like I would be totally overwhelmed
oh my god here I was absolutely
terrified but in a good way
you know I I think you I always if you
react to a script and like I've had two
experiences with wait wait what's a few
experiences scripts where I've like had
a got a reaction to something and I
haven't fully realized the thing is you
can't fully realize it until you're
right there on set so all that stuff the
groundwork that you're fighting with and
trying to suppress your fear with is is
important but ultimately what you you
know where you're working towards is
those moments on set between you and the
other person but there were a lot you
know I hadn't song in a very long time
and I had lost my nerve with it kind of
and I never really dawn country and
before so finding where that sits within
Rose Lynn's voice and where it's coming
from was a big thing and then the accent
was a big thing because it's such a part
of her character and rhythm and her
pulse and Glasgow as a character kind of
in itself in the film so getting that
right was a really big thing and then
just her swag and her and her
vulnerability and finding where that was
but I used lots of different things
pictures and different films and music
and cowboy boots
I hope those boots were comfortable it's
like I have a pair of like super cool
Frye boots and I I do love how they look
but they're uncomfortable so I kept
working
what if no they actually were I know I
wore them in well that's what's
important there I'm actually curious why
you weren't singing I feel like maybe
it's because I can't sing for the life
of me and I'm like if I could do it all
the time so what made you stop was it
all the ETV work well when I left rather
I kind of they were very like you're
going to be a clap well some people were
like you're going to be a classical
actress and I was like I hope they all
saw this particular movie in that role
and I think I kind of I done after I did
the some musical theater then went in
did jazz singing around London and I
thought I was gonna do that maybe before
I went back to Rada and I think I just
didn't really know what I want what it
was to me anymore and and yeah until I
kind of found this music in this yeah it
feels like it's come back into my life
again and I love us is it anything
specific about country music cuz I'd
like admittedly I'm not the biggest
country music fan across the board but
when I really sit and listen to it and
pay attention to like the words and the
feeling that has to go into it I kind of
I don't know I feel the warmth of it
yeah well I for me it's the lyrics and
the stories you know they're really are
they really are like three minute movies
and they have a way because the music is
very simple it's the story like off the
really good stuff where you can almost
see the scene on Ravelry you can see the
characters within it and and there's a
performer and singing and acting it's
really taught me a lot because you kind
of have to let the song come out and be
something different every single night
because the character has changed and
they've got different stories every day
and it's really the lyrics and there's
like there's a real honesty in there but
there's also irony because they like
take very normal mundane day-to-day life
experiences like a woman like angel for
Montgomery like this old woman who's
sitting in her kitchen wondering why why
she's wasted a whole
life and she's hearing the fly and she's
thinking about the cowboy that she was
with once and but she still just in her
kitchen so yeah what is it like when
you're actually performing these songs
on set like one are you doing any live
singing on set while you're shooting oh
yeah I was on live I had a feeling in
that case especially in the scenes where
I think you know it's almost shot with
like a little bit of a music video vibe
how many times do you have to do that
over in order to get all the coverage I
think like when we did the last song we
shot maybe did that like 28 times like
yeah yeah and then outlaw stage wine I
mean that was a riot because as well as
Tom we wanted to keep it really free and
I had no idea what it was going to do
and then the band kicked in and the
whole crowd were there and I don't know
I think at one point I ended up doing
the worm on the floor pops my shoulder
out of jumping down off the stage and I
really want to see some like a b-roll
now that that scene in particular was
the first time in the movie that I
caught myself it's like you know when
you're watching a movie and it's like
dark and no one could see you but all of
a sudden you realize what your face is
doing and I was just like the biggest
freaking grin on my face you're just
sitting there last man thankfully the
only one looking at me was my cat now
I'm just like way way too long I also
really wanted to ask you because we
didn't talk about this last time about
working with Sophie because she has just
been someone who's caught my eye for so
many years and I feel like nobody's
talking about her work enough but she
winds up being so important to Rosalyn's
journey throughout the entire thing so
I'm just curious what it was like
working with her oh she's like amazing
and I've loved her forever you know in
college she's definitely somebody that I
looked up to and and she's just she's
just part of the team you know that was
amazing thing between Sophie and and
Julie like Tom just gets these
incredible people who are just game you
know there's no
rigmarole are like diva or whatever we
were just all having such a good time
and so getting to get common set and
stand-ups that these amazing women just
made it so easy and enjoyable and
lightened and also made you kind of you
thought you could go anywhere and she's
just I love her she's an amazing woman
she really is so you said you had a good
time but there's a couple of like super
emotional beats in this story so I was
wondering do you have to do any kind of
like detox after walking away from
something like that
yeah oh the whiskey's talks I am aware
of that detox I don't even act no I
don't ever usually like oh I don't know
maybe I should well I I don't know I
just get on with my day really go home
get as much sleep as I can and get ready
for the next day oh it's funny I suppose
some of those scenes as well you're
subconsciously
you're you know there are some scenes
where I think I've lived with Rosalind
for a while now and those emotional ones
it was more the lead-up to them that I
found the line between us both it was
quite small and I don't know if I was
having a panic attack or she was one of
us and yeah I don't know what's
interesting what do you like to go to
set with do you like break down script
and have it in your hand or is it just a
cup of coffee
Oh always coffee smart and usually my
script is pretty crumpled and in one of
my big pockets that I'm like trying to
pull out and I don't know it's a bit of
a man I'm a bit chaotic
I like chaos and order I feel like
that's an appropriate way to approach
this particular role to like it would
almost be like anti rose to go with
everything like bullet point it out yeah
that's what I thought too yeah thing is
all my characters are like the ones that
are more but often what kind of movies
and shows are you into just like in your
free time
oh god
I just watched shoplifters on the plane
that's an amazing flats a really good
one I love
I watched succession amazing writing got
any Paul Thomas Anderson films Lynn
Ramsay films not the Ryder I feel like
you could see you and Vicky crepes in a
movie together and I'd be happy there's
another name we're not talking about her
you know she was so good at music so
good everybody loved her she just seems
like the noises coolest person I know
why first she can't actually now that
I'm thinking about she came by for when
we had this show on a shorter iteration
and we sat and we made little paper
dolls every little elf it's al she's
she's really wonderful yeah all right
love her yeah is there anybody else in
the industry because we're always
talking about like the way movies and TV
could be changing for the better and
there's a couple of like really
formidable forces out there that are
like pushing things forward in a very
promising positive direction are there
any ladies in Hollywood that you're
looking at you're like you're doing
something special right now I want to
work with you yeah well I love Lynn
Ramsay my love her films love Frances
McDormand badassness and and I love that
she let her set like how she she's just
so seeable you know you just see she
just any mask is removed it's very
amazing Olivia Colman Chloe Zhao who did
the writers yes writers great yeah
there's an amazing new writer called
Elizabeth Sanders who's from New York
who's writing amazing scripts and yeah
there's like I don't know I feel I look
around all the time and see people that
I think you're doing some things you
know true and of yourself that's awesome
any opportunity I get to put a spotlight
on names like those I'll always take it
back to Wild Rose really quickly because
you've been on like a really long press
and festival journey with this are you
sick of seeing me no not one bit but I
I do remember that I was in Toronto for
TIFF and you were lucky enough to talk
to our own Steve Wang Chao while I was
out and about doing the the hotel junket
ones and I was so sad that I missed you
guys but being on this journey for so
long is there anything about that like
really intense like press processor
sharing your movie with different
audiences in different states and
countries that has like really struck
you yeah I mean it really is different
in every place and I think you know
that's a funny I always you think all
film is just like its solidified and
it's real and that's it but it it
changes with every different audience
and every different like you know you
bring it to Austin or Nashville and
there are such hardcore country fans
that it's completely different
relationship for them or you bring it to
Glasgow and it's like a love song to
them you know it's belongs to their more
yeah I think the through thing with this
film is that it's it's a prison-break
film for anybody who's been told they're
not allowed dream outside the four walls
that they've been told they're allowed
to exist and whether you're from
Nashville or Glasgow or a man or a woman
you know belong it it can belong to
everybody I hope I really like the sound
of it that's a beautiful way to put it
it's it's a movie also that Lake told
you you could you could have everything
like I feel like we're also trained to
say like if that's mic like exclusively
my dream and nothing else
yeah yeah especially as mother's the
owner and I told you have to put your
dreams to the side once you become yeah
it's important for people to keep
nurturing their own individuality and
identity and sometimes that's hard
touching on something you said before I
do you have any movie that you've
watched that after I don't know not
liking it at one point in your life it
wound up meaning a lot to you because
it's one of my favorite things about
movies is that whether it's like the
region you're from your background
anything at all what part of your life
you're in the middle of right now what
you're dealing with the gear reaction to
the same movie could change depending on
where you stand at that moment excellent
question
well I went I saw two months a few weeks
ago in London
haven't seen in ages and I think when I
was young I didn't really like I didn't
really get hurt but I just had the best
time watching it and all of those scenes
were just each scene could be it's a
film in itself like though the the
dynamic between those characters you oh
my god yeah why don't I there's I I
always watch meet me in st. Louie like
every year at Christmastime and that it
still is magic to me but I don't know
maybe I look at different things in it
because of it I don't know what it says
about me that that is like your yearly
watching thingy and mine is
trick-or-treat on Halloween what are the
goals from here on out are there any
like specific types of projects that
you've never worked on that you've got
your eye on um I don't really plan I
don't know I I think yeah I like well I
love I love collaborating and I love the
you know I like being free in my work
and and thing is you do meet different
stories at different points in your life
and so I could have read a script I got
a red beast now on it would have been a
completely different film for me and I
probably wouldn't have been it would
have been a different story as well
because of where I am
I'm not who I say I am
understand
because we're the same I I don't know
there's I'm curious about yeah I don't
know maybe just collaborate to build
something from the roof up and see what
happened you're interested in writing
and directing at all not really no I
don't think I'd be very good at this
although I think it's such a specific
talent that you know like I appreciate
and I respect it and I think it takes
years to life mm-hmm you know oh I get
that say what you need to say with that
but I'd like to be part of that team I
love I love that like that's my favorite
way of working is from day one you're
sharing you know and whatever it is if
it's a promotes a poem to a piece of art
to a piece of music to film reference
that there's this cooking part of
something and like it I they used to
have in the Disney rooms they said these
old Disney rooms where all the writers
will go in and they'd as they were
walking through the door they'd each
have marker pen and the walls be all
completely white and whatever um like
thought they had in their head they
would just scroll it on the wall and so
all of these writers would come you know
and I mean it's kind of like what my
rooms right now but it was all around
and then they would amalgamate all the
best ideas and create a film that's why
I want to do that I mean collaboration
is key and it's also the cool thing now
to that I see all over the place is that
most people when they get a wonderful
opportunity and start to build like a
name for themselves then they can like
swing that weight around in a way where
it's like building and fostering a
project from the ground up and I don't
know make it something that's really
important to you yeah yeah yeah so
what's the deal with this live
performance now because I want to know
how I can see you performing this stuff
live oh we're doing a few live
performances while we're in the u.s. and
then we go back to the UK we're doing
some music festivals and doing
I suppose it feels like it's kind of
wrong
not the whole journey or version so we
finish at Glastonbury on the 30th of
June and one of the stages there and
we're doing a tour of Glasgow and
Belfast and Dublin and yeah
Rosedale harland's got her own tour boss
which she's very excited about yeah I
can't wait have you ever done you know
like most we're bus living or maybe even
like an RV type trip no no not like that
I'm sure music shouldn't anyone who
watches me like she's gonna get so bored
of that very late right in the middle of
almost famous now yeah I really like
that'll be a good time especially if you
have all the essentials on the tour bus
yeah yeah just blue M&Ms no I love and I
love my band there I just can't wait to
get out gigging and yeah play music with
live audience you'd be grateful it
really does sound like that's a
wonderful opportunity especially with
the music from this film I also have to
ask you about what you're doing next
because I feel like my brief scroll down
your IMDB page the Doctor Dolittle movie
is on there isn't it I just felt like a
surprising choice because with your work
I've gone from taboo to this and then I
see that it's the first thing everyone
always asked me but I haven't got a clue
where a dr. Doolittle is there what's up
with you so I thought that like two
years ago but yeah I I mean I shot
something I don't know if they've caught
me on the floor if I'm there or not but
I know maybe you see if the [ __ ] I do
and you can let me know I will we also
do some Collider random questions just
to get to know you a little bit better I
have a feeling I know the answer to this
specific one but what's the movie you
quote the most is that a gun in your
pocket are you just happy to see me or
the mask it's a tommy gun pa rt why
because I got a pa rt why because I I'm
telling you I feel like they should
remake that movie and you should be an
ass longer film it loves you very well
that is like my generation like growing
up experience the movie was way too
important to me I mean I don't know how
I found Lauren Bacall and the mask I'm
sure the guy absolutely I don't know
what she'd say to me any movie or TV
memorabilia or props at home basically
did you steal anything
oh because I feel like there's lots from
Wild Rose to see oh I mean I have I have
of the whole costume I've even brought
my wild dogs Jack italiancakes like you
know moment it took me I feel like you
guys should actually like do something
to promote the film where you're selling
those jackets I would I wanted to open a
tattoo pop-up tattoo parlor oh that was
my other question for this is I mean
this is so silly but I always think of
little details like that that tattoo
like are they basically applying it
every single yeah it's a whole skill my
favorite was Chuck he never really came
out I had this cowboy on my chest which
we call Chuck I think we should do
pop-up wild rose tattoo parlours don't
say that because I would do it real
that's we should do it I'm very like
easily influenced when it comes to
tattoos great I thought well last time I
was here I got a tattoo on my lunch
break which is a really bad idea did you
really yeah what did you get I mean this
but it looks like blue tooth but it's
actually not wait what is it it's well
oh it's it's a it's from beast and
Johnny had all these symbols on the
inside of his finger which were like
Nordic sick signs for different things
this is a Nordic sign for growth but it
just looks like bluetooth and I saw my
brother and he was like that's the
stupidest thing I ever saw the point is
that means something to you yeah
embarrassment yeah that's that's my next
spout I'm gonna wind up with something
right there too and it's not gonna be
exactly that but for some reason I feel
like I'm it's gonna comfortable so I'm
gonna break and template together gross
but then I think you know that is down a
different path it's gonna have to be a
classy one classy rose
I could see that it would be a nice one
um if you had the opportunity to guest
on any TV show out there right now what
would it be uh Breaking Bad Breaking Bad
is never a wrong answer to any question
session I love successions I need to
watch the colon cuz like I watched most
of the HBO programming and it's like
every time that trailer comes on I
always say to myself I should watch that
and for whatever reason I just there's
so much content yeah yeah what is the so
I'm purposely gunning for something
right now what is the most importantly
Oh cut my hair I cut my hair oh but I
can't even remember that I did this yeah
I caught all my hair off god I used to
do this thing after I finished job well
because sometimes that feels like your
hair belongs to a character and so I'd
like go home and I'd be like oh I need
to cut my hair off so I'd like to just
cut myself in this really bad Bob and
for years it was going in to my
hairdresser and I'd be like oh god is
playing another crazy woman I had to cut
my hair was so bad it was literally like
choppy like a bit rocky it's back kind
of a mullet growing out my mom feels
like a weird fear and me as a child
where it's like if I cut a single piece
of hair I was gonna ruin everybody like
a good portion of my adult life always
having to go in and pay to get my bangs
cut I'm just so afraid to cut one hair
before we wrap this up
is there anything coming out movie or TV
wise that you are really looking forward
to I can't wait to see Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood um I don't really know what
else is about to come out what is about
to come out oh my god so much what's
what your go-to genre like Paul Thomas
Anderson Paul time I think we might have
to wait a little while for more from him
probably like I don't know maybe I like
realist do you get the chance to explore
any of the other films the festivals
while you're there or is it all like
work work work
sometimes I sometimes wish I could see
more like why I love food festival I saw
quite so Roma in the cinema which they
loved yeah I tried I saw a white boy
Rick when I was at Toronto yeah yeah
that played there too I just thought of
something that I feel like you're gonna
like broken circle breakdown what have
you ever heard of that no I believe it's
a film that takes place it's a Belgian
film and it's got like the the bluegrass
music vibe and it's some like I mean
like beautiful another one that I
couldn't stop listening to after I saw
it but it's also like a real
heartbreaker Oh story but that is
phenomenal from the director who did a
beautiful boy oh cool
[Music]
[Music]
you know it's more important right now
that all of you check out Wild Rose
seriously I can't reiterate it enough
you are something special that's in that
movie you really need to see it thank
you so much for your time having you
here guys thanks so much for watching
this episode of Collider ladies night as
always like and share and we're gonna
see you soon with more of them
[Applause]
[Music]